Story I will start from where the story actually is
for embarry.
Those is the name of the guy.
Moving to the UK has seemed like a chance to transform
his family's future.
The father of three uprooted his life in Kenya to come.
He sought his belongings,
left his job
and paid 2,500 in admin fees to a dominionary agency
which he claims promised him a full time
minimum wage job and times what he would make back home.
But last week,
less than a year after he arrived,
he says he was forced to return to Nairobi
with £10,000 in debt.
With no job to go back home to,
he claims his employer fired him
and terminated his visa sponsorship
after he raised concerns about working conditions.
It then failed to provide him with reference, he says,
to what's in his chances of finding another care
sector sponsor
and leaving him unable to remain in the UK.
The company denies wrongdoing
and disputes embarrassed accounts.
When embarrassed began working in the UK
in September 2022,
he found a job tough
but rewarding.
He says he formed close bond with his client,
mostly elderly people receiving end of life care,
and was treated by some relatives as part of the family.
But the conditions were not what he had expected.
Before leaving Kenya,
he says was told by his sponsor
which is Merit Healthcare,
and I mentioned the name of the company
because I don't want anybody to fall victim Okay,
that is why I am naming them so
married healthcare
that he would work 40 hours per week for ten pounds
twenty pence per hour,
the contrasting to be about £21,200 per earning
split into even monthly payment.
However, when he arrived
he received five fewer jobs,
which he said
left him struggling to afford basic living cost.
Sometimes he was set off for the day before 7:00am
and return eleven PM,
but spent as little as two or three hours
providing care to client,
split into half hour chunks.
With long gaps between appointments
and no pay for driving or waiting time,
he found himself with long periods unpaid.
He could have gone home to rest instead of waiting,
but says he would not afford the extra fuel.
Pays list for September to January 2023
shows embarring made between £980
£2,100 each month,
which is hundreds less than what he was expecting.
His Amor income would have been around 12,000 to 13,000
with debt and school fees to pay.
Embarassevered at first,
desperate to make enough after rent and bills
to send money to his family.
Then four months in,
he says merit
which is the company
insisted he agrees for a vehicle policy
requiring him to pay the cost of road tax,
insurance and upkeep for the company car
used for driving between clients,
which he had previously funded.
Alternatively,
he could buy a car at cost price
and have a monthly fee taken from his salary
embarrass Says the charges would have cost
him hundreds of pounds each month.
I thought I didn't have to be a slave, he says.
I don't know how I would even pay it back.
Documents show that embarries concerns,
with a manager
hoping the situation will be resolved.
Days later the company fired him
and told the Home Office
it was cancelling his visa sponsorship.
In a termination letter on 20th January 2023,
Merit, which is the name of the company,
said he was being dismissed
for failure to comply with the new vehicle rules.
It also accused him of insubordination
by inciting other employees to disagree with
our policies.
The company
to the observer
it had fired in Bara for legal and valid reasons
but could not supply further details
due to data Protection rules.
Now I'm back with his family in Georgia,
a town North East of Nairobi.
The former company
says he does not know how
they will repay £10,000 in debts
he include in agency fee,
training charges,
flight relocation cost
and interest on loans
which he had expected to be able to repay
through the UK job.
He expects he would have to sell
the house his family builds.
I thought this job would make my life better, he says.
History has spark calls
for recall to the tide visa
system in the UK care sector,
which campaign is say
leave migrants
workers at risk of exploitation and abuse.
A lot is going on
with this dumbsiliary care Especially,
it is a job that is tedious